what's the stellar in our project is a
Salesman but an eye and you can find us
on facebook salesman two works and so
it's a short film about two bumbling
salesman selling sailing vacations in
san diego and chris is one of our
customers yes we sell we sell
door-to-door shenanigans consumes we're
not that good at go to door sales yeah
why did you make AI realize there is a
shortage me actually it's we want to
eventually pitch it as a television show
and at first it was just something to do
wanted to stay busy and it was Brian and
I are both riders and it was just
something to do that we can do ourselves
and then once we got more involved in
the writing and production we kind of
fell in love with it so much we decided
to pitch it as television show so that's
where we're wanting to go in the house
so we figured using the medium of the
shore Gregor enable us to show that we
can create a 12-episode are just kind of
further our own artistic credibility
yeah yeah you know something to show up
that we can do you know have a resume
a lot of fun brave enough to take up all
of his clothes great I'm working on it